question est faite au nom du droit du
salut public citoyen veiller sur la cité
qui vous est confiée demain vous seriez
avec l'armée les vengeurs de la patrie
hôtel de ville de paris le 4 septembre
1870 signé emmanuel arago adolphe
crémieux
pierre frédéric d'orient jules favre
jules ferry
guillaume montpeyroux léon gambetta lui
antoine garnier pagès joseph pierre
magnin francisco ordinaire pierre albert
achard et gêne pas le teint airness
picard et julie 6
[Applaudissements]
madame monsieur le ministre
madame le maire de paris
sept députés
c'est le préfet de police mesdames
messieurs à vos grades et qualités cher
matthew noura patricia catherine anna le
moment je mesure pour vous pour vos
familles est à la fois émouvant et
solennel
non seulement vous accomplissez un rêve
devenir français mais vous le faites
dans un lieu à part notre panthéon
là où reposent les grandes femmes les
grands hommes
honoré par notre patrie la vôtre
désormais et qui plus est cette
cérémonie de naturalisation se tient le
jour même où la république célèbre son
anniversaire
c'était le 4 septembre 1870 alors que l'
empire venait d'être défait à sedan un
jeune député de 32 ans léon gambetta
répondaient à l'appel du peuple de paris
et proclamé la république depuis le
balcon de l'hôtel de ville
léon gambetta dont nous venons
d'entendre les mots étaient comme vous
un fils d'immigré
récent naturalisé français de sang mêlé
c'est lui pourtant qui ressuscite à la
république ce régime politique de
liberté sous lequel nous vivons depuis
150 ans le pays manquait de se briser la
république
une fois encore le sauvage il y attend
d'autres léon gambetta tant de figures
françaises non par héritage mais par les
combats menés qui ont façonné notre
histoire
marie curie na qui ai grandi en pologne
elle reçu deux prix nobel fit le choix
de servir la france dans les tranchées
comme simple infirmière avant d'ouvrir
aux femmes de portes qui leur étaient
jusque là fermé celle des chaires
d'enseignement de la sorbonne et les
portes de bronze du panthéon
joséphine baker n'est américaine choisi
la france pour la faire briller de son
talent et de son énergie l aimer sa
patrie d'adoption au point de risquer sa
vie pour elle en entrant dans la
résistance tant et tant de destins
devenu français ainsi par leur combat
bien d'autres héros
français par la naissance n'est parfois
si loin de la métropole ont porté si
haut nos valeurs et marquer
l'édification de notre république félix
éboué descendants d'esclaves répondit
dès le 18 juin à l'appel du général de
gaulle il fut le premier à planter
l'étendard de la france libre au tchad
107 enfants de notre guyane qui allait
devenir compagnon de la libération est
reposant ces lieux lui aussi l'épopée
des forces françaises libres n'aurait
pas été la même
comment ne pas évoquer gisèle halimi
disparu cet été de sa chère tunisie à
notre assemblée nationale des prétoires
vos hémicycle de plaidoyer en manif est
celle qui était né à isa tayeb plaida
pour l'émancipation des peuples et fit
faire des bonds de géant à la cause des
femmes
un hommage national lui sera
prochainement rendue dans la cour des
invalides
léon gambetta marie curie félix éboué
joséphine baker gisèle halimi
autant d'exemples avec d'autres figures
que nous mettons à l'honneur en ce jour
de vie en république autant de destins
dont matthew n'aura patricia catherine
rana
vous êtes aujourd'hui délégataire car
c'est votre tour désormais votre tour
aux côtés de tous les enfants de la
république par leur naissance et de
tenter tant d'autres
par delà la diversité de vos origines
vous qui venez du royaume uni d'algérie
du cameroun du pérou ou du liban décrire
vos vies en république
je ne parle pas là de façonner vos
existences personnel vous avez tous déjà
un métier souvent une famille mais
d'endosser pleinement les habits de
citoyens français en vous hissant au
delà de vous même devenir français c'est
en effet accepté d'être plus qu'un
individu
poursuivant ses intérêts propres un
citoyen qui concourt au bien commun fait
preuve de responsabilité vis-à-vis de
ses compatriotes qui cultive une vertu
tout républicaine des devoirs
et des droits mais toujours des devoirs
d'abord devenir français c'est avoir
ancré en soi même la conscience que
parce que la république est toujours
fragile toujours précaire elle doit être
un combat de chaque courbe une conquête
de chaque jour un patriotisme
républicain de chaque instant la
république n'est pas donné jamais
acquise et je le dis ici aussi pour nos
jeunes c'est une conquête
elle est toujours à protéger ou à
reconquérir la liberté d'abord liberté
liberté chérie entonne la marseillaise
être français c'est d'abord aimer
passionnément la liberté de gaulle a
évoqué le pacte 20 fois séculaire entre
la france et la liberté du monde à
partir d'aujourd'hui vous êtes liés par
ce pacte la liberté dans notre
république est un bloc c'est la liberté
de participer au choix de ses dirigeants
est donc le droit de vote mais qui est
indissociable de la soumission au
verdict des urnes à la liberté
collective du peuple c'est la liberté de
conscience et en particulier la laïcité
ce régime unique au monde qui garantit
la liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
mais qui n'est pas séparable d'une
liberté d'expression allant jusqu'au
droit au blasphème et je le dis au
moment où s'ouvre le procès des
attentats de janvier 2015
être français c'est défendre le droit de
faire rire la liberté de rails et de
moquer de caricaturer dont voltaire
soutenait qu'elle était la source de
toutes les autres être français c'est
être toujours du côté des combattants de
la liberté et plus encore quand les
renoncements prospère quand la censure
progresse l'égalité être français
c'est reconnaître en chaque femme en
chaque homme une même dignité
être français s'étaient aimés la justice
abolition des privilèges et déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
1789 suffrage universel masculin et
abolition de l'esclavagé par seule chair
en 1848 droit de vote des femmes en 1944
abaissement de la majorité à 18 ans en
1974 abolition de la peine de mort en
vous vous inscrivez dans une belle et
grande histoire celle du progrès de
l'égalité des droits
vous êtes aussi les continuateurs d'une
marche encore inachevé vers l'égalité
concrètes effectif peggy jaurès blum
mendès france ont porté haut la
république sociale cette idée ce un
bureau font chaque citoyen quel que soit
le lieu où il vit le milieu d'où il
vient
doit pouvoir construire sa vie par son
travail par son mérite
nous sommes encore loin
trop loin de cet idéal
combien encore d'enfants de france sont
discriminés pour leur couleur de peau
leur nom combien de portes fermées à
deux jeunes femmes deux hommes parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas les bons codes
n'était pas né au bon endroit
l'égalité des chances n'est pas encore
effective aujourd'hui dans notre
république
c'est pourquoi elle est plus que jamais
une priorité de ce quinquennat
nous irons plus loin plus fort dans les
semaines à venir pour que la promesse
républicaine soient tenus dans le
concret des vies mais l'égalité elle
aussi est un bloc les devoirs et des
droits
l'égalité devant la loi implique ainsi
que les lois de la république sont
toujours supérieurs aux règles
particulières c'est pourquoi il n'y aura
jamais de place en france pour ceux qui
souvent au nom d'un dieu parfois avec
l'aide de puissances étrangères
entendent imposer la loi d'un groupe non
la république parce qu'elle est
indivisible n'a mené aucune aventure
séparatistes un projet de loi de lutte
contre le séparatisme sera à cette fin
présentée dès cet automne la fraternité
être français c'est voir en son
compatriote pink un semblable un des
siens notre nation a ceci de singulier
qu'elle a développé un état providence
un modèle de protection sociale qui ne
laisse personne au bord du chemin
or ce système unique au monde ne tient
que par les liens toujours fragile qui
unissent nos concitoyens liens du
respect et de la civilité qu'à tout
moment la violence et la haine peuvent
briser
c'est pour cela qu'en république les
policiers les gendarmes les magistrats
les maires les élus de la république
plus largement toutes celles et ceux qui
luttent contre la violence contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme jouent un
rôle déterminant et que par symétrie
ceux qui s'en prennent à eux doivent
être lourdement condamné force à la loi
jamais à l'arbitraire ceux qui s'en
prennent aux forces de l'ordre
aux élus ne passeront pas lien de la
solidarité de l'engagement
notre état providence a une nouvelle
fois montré lors de la pandémie que nous
venons de traverser sa force en
accompagnant chaque français et nous
nous souviendrons longtemps du courage
de nos soignants du dévouement des
bénévoles de l'entr'aide entre voisins
qui nous ont permis de faire face au
plus fort de la crise mais là encore la
fraternité est un bloc elle ne peut
vivre perdure et que si chacun reconnaît
l'autre comme digne d'être aidé et
accompagné
elle repose sur chaque citoyen aussi et
pas simplement sur un état qui donnerait
des droits c'est pourquoi le partage
d'un commun est décisif
des sacrifices pour mes compatriotes que
si je me sens lié à eux non seulement
par un contrat social mais par des
références une culture une histoire
commune des valeurs communes
un destin commun dans lequel nous sommes
engagés c'est cela la république la
france écrivait marc bloch et la patrie
dont je ne saurais déracinés mon coeur
j'ai bu aux sources de sa culture j'ai
fait mien sont passées je ne respire
bien que sous son ciel et je me suis
efforcé à mon tour de la défendre de mon
mieux
c'est tout cela entrée en république
française et met nos paysages notre
histoire notre culture en bloque
toujours le sacre de reims et la fête de
la fédération
c'est pour cela que la république ne
déboulonne pas de statut ne choisit pas
simplement une part de son histoire car
on ne choisit jamais une part de france
ont choisi la france la république
commence vous l'avez compris bien avant
la république elle-même car ces valeurs
sont enracinées dans notre histoire et
devenir français c'est l'épousé tout
entière c'est aussi épousé une langue
qui ne s'arrête pas à nos frontières
vous le savez parfaitement mais qui fut
aussi l'un des ciments de notre nation
ma patrie c'est la langue française
écrivez camus maîtriser le français
permet bien sûr de communiquer
d'échanger avec ses compatriotes de
comprendre notre droit et c'est pour
cela que la langue est un pré requis
pour accéder à la nationalité mais
maîtriser le français
c'est un passeport
vers une culture une histoire
incomparable aux dimensions des cinq
continents
c'est accéder à l'imaginaire de hugo
dumas zola malraux césaire tous ici
honoré au panthéon
c'est accompagné les personnages de
mauriac disparu il ya 50 ans de tous ces
écrivains dont la grandeur au nord non
seulement l'esprit français
mais le génie universel maîtriser notre
langue c'est plus encore toucher l'âme
de la nation une forme d'éternel
français la france est en effet l'un des
rares pays qui avec l'ordonnancé de
villers-cotterêts de 15 139 a été comme
créé engendrés par sa langue notre
langue à forger notre rapport à la
liberté à l'universel l'abbé grégoire
qui reposent ici lui aussi ne disait-il
pas que le français il idiome de la
liberté notre langue est le berceau de
la république
bien avant qu'elle ne soit proclamé par
les conventionnels de 1792
parce que la république prend forme déjà
dans les textes de baudin à la
renaissance
elle s'affirme chez condorcet rousseau
et tous les penseurs des lumières
notre langue c'est ce qui tient notre
peuple
notre histoire c'est ce qui fait que
charles péguy pouvait clamer la
république notre royaume de france en
france décidément tout commence par les
mots la république c'est une
transmission et la république
est une volonté jamais achevée toujours
à reconquérir
et si elle tient depuis la révolution
c'est parce qu'entre ceux qui l'ont rêvé
ce qu'ils ont fait à devenir ce qu'ils
ont défendu parfois dans les heures les
plus tragiques de notre histoire
ce qu'ils ont renouvelé dans le projet
européen entre toutes ces femmes et
toutes ces sommes c'est nous et une
chaîne des temps qui a traversé les
siècles et en ce jour anniversaire ce
n'est pas tant la joie qui domine
je dois bien l'avouer qu'une forme de
gravité lucide face aux menaces qui
pèsent sur elle alors matthew noura
patricia catherine rana
c'est à vous aujourd'hui de reprendre le
flambeau avec beaucoup d'autres de faire
vivre la promesse républicaine dans ces
bourrasques des temps reprendre le
flambeau et le confier à notre jeunesse
représentée par des collégiens qui nous
entoure ce matin notre jeunesse qui doit
continuer de garder ce goût des rites
républicains
le service national universel beaucoup
d'autres institutions y concourent
notre école républicaine en à la mission
et nos professeurs continuent d'en
porter l'exigence notre jeunesse de
france
à qui je souhaite d'aimer la république
d'une passion toujours intacte
ne croyez pas que ce ne sont que des
mots c'est toute une histoire
ce sont ces destins et je n'ai parlé que
de quelques-uns et mellal d'une passion
toujours renouvelée parce que mesuré
chaque jour que c'est elle qui vous
permet d'être des citoyens libres c'est
elle qui vous a fait naître libre qui
vous permet d'apprendre d'être élevée
dans la liberté de juger de savoir de
construire votre vie libre non ça n'est
pas donnée par tout ça n'est pas été
donnée de tout temps alors à chaque fois
que le drapeau tombera il faudra leur
lycée à chaque fois que certains la
menace rond il faudra la défendre car
d'autres avant vous l'ont défendu soyons
donc tous rassemblés vous qui venez de
rejoindre la communauté nationale
vous qui y est né et qui ai grandi c'est
et tous les enfants de la république
être français n'est jamais seulement une
identité c'est une citoyenneté
ce sont des droits qui vont avec ce sont
aussi ses devoirs c'est à dire
l'adhésion à ses valeurs à une histoire
à une langue à une exigence qui tient la
république debout car elle dépend de
chacune et chacun d'entre nous à chaque
instant c'est un combat chaque jour
recommencer
alors ensemble formant cette france unie
qui peut tout vaincre et parce que avec
leur force d'âme
certaines et certains rejoignent
aujourd'hui la république et que vous
aurez en reprendre le flambeau
alors avec confiance oui nous pourrons
continuer encore longtemps de dire vive
la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allons enfants de la patrie le jour de
gloire est arrivé contre nous est la
tyrannie
les tendances en blanc
les traces d antan
[Musique]
il
sur aube a égorgé